good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i'm proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021
2022 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health institute
of virginia the uva brain institute the college
of arts and sciences the school of data science
and through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial intelligence and
biomedicine where we are enjoying presentations
on friday afternoons from leading thinkers about
the promise opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical sciences
sciences selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital material
for our culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to be held here in historic
charlottesville virginia next june applications
for the biomedical data science innovation
lab program are still being accepted up until
january 31st 2022 so please do consider applying
or encouraging your junior colleagues to do so
we look forward to reviewing these application
materials today it is my honor and privilege
to welcome our speaker dr jennifer miller from
yale university school of medicine dr miller is
an assistant professor and director of the good
pharma scorecard a ranking of pharmaceutical
companies on their bioethics and social
responsibility performance and she is the founder
of the non-profit bio bioethics international
prior to joining yale's faculty dr miller
was based at the new york university school
of medicine also at duke university and at
harvard university she's been a member of the
world economic forum and co-founder of the new
bioethics publication with scientific american
called good medicine her current work centers
on ethics equity and data sharing in biomedical
research she is a recognized leader in empirical
bioethics and developing and using metrics to
enhance accountability across the pharmaceutical
industry she also explores the ethics and social
concerns around the use of big data in a.i in
medicine and in biomedical research she has over
80 peer-reviewed publications including periodic
uh articles appearing in periodicals such as
nature medicine health affairs jama oncology
the british medical journal and tri and uh
uh and and has been the recipients because we have
multiple grants she's a frequent news commentator
and featured on cbs news wall street journal and
among other places uh in continuing our 2021-2022
biomedical data science seminar series theme
jennifer's lecture today is entitled ethics equity
and transparency in biomedical research and
the role of the good pharma scorecard she's
going to draw upon her wealth of experience in
bioethics and pharmaceutical fields by discussing
transparency and data sharing and in addition
in addition she will cover the importance of
equitable access to the benefits of biomedical
research and what is more we are super excited
to have her being serving as one of our 2021 2022
biomedical data science innovation lab mentors
we're super excited about that as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you're watching on youtube thank
you so much for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are encouraged to
submit any questions they have for jennifer
by the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will personally synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of jennifer's lecture and with that welcome
jennifer we are so excited to hear from you today
thank you jack for that overly generous
introduction and for the opportunity to
participate in today's seminar delighted to be
here as jack mentioned i'm an assistant professor
at yale school of medicine and founder of
the non-profit bioethics international which
i co-founded in 2005 to help advance ethics in
healthcare and healthcare innovation one of my
capstone projects uh as my role at yale university
and bioethics international is the good pharma
scorecard the scorecard is an index designed
to evaluate and rank pharmaceutical biotech and
medical device companies on their bioethics and
social responsibility performance annually the
process involves developing bioethics standards
and accountability metrics uh for companies
and then using those metrics to evaluate and rank
companies year after year to help us do three
things track our progress industry's progress
on bioethics goals over time catalyze or incent
improved behaviors where needed and recognize
and celebrate where there are best practices
so for today's seminar i'm going to begin by
briefly introducing the good from a scorecard and
show how it currently works measuring and ranking
companies on their transparency and data sharing
practices by reviewing the latest 2021 good pharma
scorecard rankings and then we'll dive into some
new measures that we're developing and piloting
for the scorecard which are focused on equity in
biomedical research or more specifically equitable
access to the benefits of clinical research
so let's begin with an introduction the
scorecard is currently focused on the role of
industry in biomedical research because industry
sponsors the vast majority of clinical research
particularly clinical research supporting
fda approval of our new medicines
by vaccines and biologics and devices we
built the scorecard based on a review of
75 quality improvement strategies like
accreditation certification ratings and rankings
so you can think of the u.s news and world report
rankings of best colleges for um the restaurant
grades that you might see on a restaurant
window uh depending on its cleanliness a b and c
and it's also we also built the good firm
scorecard based on a review of the literature
which generally shows that these types of quality
improvement strategies can help improve practices
within companies so on the screen you'll see one
study sponsored by colleagues at harvard and duke
which reviewed 598 firms subject to ratings and
found that low scoring firms substantially improve
practices uh when they get a low score supporting
the old adage what gets measured gets done
so the scorecard is designed to comprehensively
address the key bioethics concerns
about the pharmaceutical medical device
and biotech sectors however we have only
publicly debuted so far our rankings on
transparency and data sharing practices
and we decided to prioritize transparency
as our initial uh starting place because
in the first place there was robust evidence
uh suggesting a potential widespread transcen
transparency problem in clinical research
so on the screen you see one example of a
study conducted by monique anderson and rob
califf who were both at duke at the time
published in new england journal of medicine
showing that 20 of registered clinical trials had
reported results in clinical trials like of the
nih registry within one year of their completion
and even if you looked at five years after the
completion you still could only find about 50
of trials having public results in the registry
so along with uh evidence of a potential problem
we also recognize the importance of clinical
trial transparency for quality patient care
it's hard to practice evidence-based
medicine if you have incomplete or biased
data also it is important for innovation
as scientists benefit from building upon
the knowledge and research of other scientists
and honoring and protecting research participants
we don't often think about you know why are we
justified in allowing medical experimentation
on people on humans and one of the reason is
its potential to contribute to generalizable
knowledge that can help people which is hard
to accomplish when or if results and data
remain behind locked doors and further
transparency is important for trust
and we're focused on trustworthiness and
appropriate trust in a sector a recent
study by pew or a survey found that 57 percent of
adults say they trust scientific research findings
more if the researchers made their data publicly
available and as we're seeing right now and know
from the study from the literature distrust can
result in disengagement from a system and in
this case hesitancy to use products like vaccines
we're seeing this with covid19 vaccines right now
so the good from a scorecard 2021 rankings we have
five years of rankings and i'll just uh present
your the most recent findings uh the 2021 rankings
which came out in july or the summer of 2021 this
year focused on companies with a novel drug
or biologic like a vaccine approved by the fda
in 2016 and 2017 and so here's what that sample
characteristics look like we ranked and evaluated
42 different companies 17 large companies and 25
non-large that sponsored a total of 62 products 40
drugs and 22 biologics which were approved based
on a thousand over a thousand clinical trials
so to score companies on their transparency and
data sharing we first assess them on the trial
level and then pool trials to get to a company
uh score so we look at three sets of trials
in a new drug application or biologics license
application basically a company submits an
application to the fda for a product approval much
like a university student might submit a college
application to a university for admissions
a company can do this to the fda for product
approval in that application all of the
trials clinical trials that the company
conducted on the experiment will be listed
in there and so what we do is we go through
every fda approval package to find all of
the clinical trials that a company conducted
and figure out the percentage of those
public results and we look at three samples
of those trials first the all trial sample which
is just what it sounds like whether all you know
the percentage of all those trials with public
results then just the trials conducted in patients
basically excluding trials and healthy volunteers
and then third just trials subject to legal
reporting requirements under u.s laws i'll dive
more into this in a second so i'm not going to go
through every product findings now the ratings
include a lot of um products but we'll we'll
go through sort of the aggregate findings
of what we found from this year's rankings
per product super drug or biologic a median
of 62 of the trials conducted for fda approval
are publicly available so 38 are publicly
unavailable on the product level only 26
of our reviewed fda approved products were fully
transparent meaning they had summary results
in a clinical trial registry or in a
publication within six months of fda approval of
the product if you narrow the sample from in all
trials to just trials conducted in patients for
the approved indication per product you'll find
that a hundred percent a median of 100 of trials
in patients per product are available but
if you look if you step back and look at
the product level still you're only
getting about two-thirds of products
with public results for their trials within
six months of fda approval of a product so
two-thirds of products are fully transparent
about the results of their patient trials
and one-third even for patient trials
are missing um results if you narrow the
sample even further to just those trials subject
to mandatory results reporting under the law
you'll still find 58 percent of products
failing to meet baseline us legal requirements
for clinical trial transparency to put these into
context a bit more per product there's a median
of 13 clinical trials in an application about
five of those are in patients for the approved
indications would be in the in the patient
trial sample and then about three of those
would be subject to mandatory uh legal disclosures
mandatory results reporting under the law
so that's the product level so now let's look
at let's aggregate up to the company level
so the company score does not include that all
trials review it includes the patient trials
score and the legal compliance score and then we
add a data sharing score so not just looking at
whether results summary results are reported
in a clinical trial registry or in a paper
but actually looking at the company commits
to sharing patient level data from a study
and here i want to mention that we also
give companies a 30-day amendment window
so we give companies their scores and we give them
30 days to improve things uh and about half of low
scoring companies have traditionally taken us
up on that offer and you can see all these green
lines and improve their practices within 30 days
of getting a low score so here's what the 2021
company rankings look like you'll see that about
58 of companies were fully transparent about
about all the trials they conducted in patients
for the approved indication for their products
42 percent of companies met um minimum
legal requirements for results reporting
and 26 met the data sharing measures overall 17 of
companies or seven out of the 42 that we reviewed
fully met all of our transparency measures
so in an effort to create a race to
the top we emphasize a leaderboard
companies that score in the top 10 and also
perfect score 100 on our measures this shows
that not only are these measures possible they're
reasonable and it highlights best practices
so these are the companies that
scored on the leaderboard this year
and we also do a deep dive factor analysis
to try and understand the root causes of uh
good and bad transparency performance and here
what you can see is looking at the association
of company size company location and product type
with transparency performance but you can see his
company's size is driving um transparency
scores and in this case non-large companies
smaller companies are less likely to comply
with laws u.s laws requiring results reporting
here you see that the median score for large
companies is 100 and non-large it's only 57
and then uh smaller companies are less likely
to have data sharing policies and data sharing
policies that meet our measures so large companies
the score is 100 on data sharing in contrast to
smaller companies we have only 20 so it's really
the small company the large companies are starting
to perform better and better and the small
companies who are new to the scorecard this year
but they're added to the scorecards the first time
this year still have a lot of room for improvement
um so we as i mentioned we've been
doing this with five years worth of data
and the good news is that we see there's some
evidence suggesting impact from the scorecard
uh in the first place the 2019 good form
of scorecard rankings published in bmj
show that half of low scoring
large companies improved their
practices and procedures within 30 days of
receiving a low good pharma scorecard a low
good from a scorecard score further the industry
company median scores are going up year after year
even though we're actually shortening
the time frame for results reporting
further um the scorecard is becoming
institutionalized within the sector
as companies when they score well are using it
in their corporate social responsibility and
human rights due diligence annual
reports and social media outreach
and so the more attention and more eyeballs
on the scorecard the more incentive
there is for other companies to improve
practices the better lever for change it becomes
we're also have partnered with scientific american
to launch a new publication called good medicine
uh which goes out to which reaches
eight to nine million people
annually so our first this is what
the first uh publication looked like
and we have worked with ernst young
in the past to sponsor our award ceremony every
year and so here you see the companies who scored
in the top five the first few years
getting their actual transparency awards
so based on this evidence suggesting a
potential impact or a likely impact we've
decided we'd like to do more and the next topic
we're going to address is equity in biomedicine
so in particular when we think about equity
or equitable access to research benefits
we're just looking at two things so far first is
demographic representation or fair inclusion in
clinical research and i'll explain what these
terms mean in a second and the second second
one is fair access to medicines and vaccines
among low and middle-income countries who help
us develop our medicines and vaccines by hosting
clinical trials so let's look at the first issue
many studies have shown that new
medicines and vaccines tend to be tested
on populations who are younger and
healthier and more likely to identify
as whites than real world patients in u.s
u.s clinical settings with studied conditions
so here you just see one study conducted by
lorraine colleagues which is showing that patients
identifying as black and hispanic patients
as black or hispanic are underrepresented in
cancer trials in proportion to the disease
burden measured by incidence and mortality
these
under representation in research is concerning for
several reasons in the one key one is it can leave
doctors payers and patients in a quandary about
how to apply trial findings to themselves or their
clinical practices when they or their patients
do not represent the racial identity ethnicity
age sex or gender of trial participants
excluding certain groups from research
can exclude them from having treatments guided by
evidence that applies to patients like them which
can potentially lead to harm exposure and lost
opportunities to pursue more effective therapies
the literature has highlighted this problem
and suggested some processes for improving it
like conducting more decentralized or community
hospital-based trials offering transportation
and child care for participants
broadening trial eligibility criteria
and there have been several highly
high profile efforts policy efforts
to diversify clinical trial participants
but all of this has had limited impact
disparities persist and here you can see a recent
editorial from the editors of new england journal
of medicine calling for a discussion about
what it means to have acceptable and reasonable
representation in clinical research and you
also see here a study from jama network open
saying we need diversity enrollment targets uh
for research because we currently don't have them
so we so when you look at the literature there
are two main ways for assessing demographic
representation in clinical research or
fair inclusion one way is to compare
the demographics of participants enrolled
in a trial to the demographics of the u.s
population the other way is a method developed
by dr rita poon who at the time was at the fda
published in 2013 which involves constructing a
participation to prevalence ratio or ppr which
you can do by dividing the percent of a particular
population in a among study participants by the
percent of that particular population in the
real world disease population so for example
if we wanted to look at women we would compare
the percent of women participating in a trial
to the proportion in the disease population it's
a pretty basic equation we our team in a study
led by a brilliant yale medical student tanvi
varma used poon's method to assess demographic
representation for novel cancer drugs approved
by the fda between 2012 and 2016. it was about 45
cancer therapeutics and the first thing to
note is that we found transparency problems um
a lot of the demographic data were not
transparent for products and trials
only 48 of pre-market studies meaning trials
conducted before approval had publicly available
ethnicity data 77 had age data and 81 had race
data sex is actually very consistently reported
and in the post-marketing
studies these numbers go down
only 30 of post-marketing studies have publicly
available ethnicity data 48 race 64 age and 75 sex
for the trials that we were able
to find the demographic composition
we then looked at representation while we
found that women were generally adequately
represented in pre and marketing studies
older adults and patients identifying
as black were underrepresented in
both pre and post marketing studies
so now our team is working on building a
company ranking informed by poon's ppr methods
to set fair inclusion targets for companies
and use those to benchmark their performance
track our progress and recognize where there are
best practices so half we anticipate half the
score looking at the transparency of demographic
data and the other half to actually look at
the composition the demographic
representation of a trial
and we'll put those scores together
to come up with a fair inclusion score
along with considering who we should
enroll in research i'm also interested
in what we might owe populations participating
in research starting with national populations
many studies have shown that clinical research
supporting u.s medicine and vaccine approvals has
been globalized and is largely conducted in other
countries increasingly lower income countries
here you see just one study focused on heart
failure trials which found participant enrollment
from north america decreased from 43 from
2001 to 2004 to 27 between 2013 to 2014.
to my knowledge the rate at which market
access to products is obtained by the countries
hosting these trials supporting fda
product approvals had not been studied
and so i sought to design a study to answer
three questions first where are novel drugs
and biologics being tested secondly how
commonly and quickly are these medicines
approved for marketing in the countries where they
are tested and three are there any differences
occurring in these approvals by country
income and geographic or geographic regions
before i go over the results i want
to say that marketing access meaning
whether a country approves a product first
for marketing does not guarantee a patient
can afford a product or vaccine or that there is
a reasonable supply but is generally a critical
precondition for those later important stage
access issues so this is why we started with
marketing approval to begin with so this sample
looked at fda approved drugs in 2012 and 2014
sponsored by large companies large companies
were defined as the 20 largest by market cap
so our sample looked at in the fda approved a
total of 79 novel drugs in 2012 and 2014. 34 of
which or 43 were sponsored by large pharmaceutical
companies approved based on a total of 898 trials
63 of which had publicly available trial locations
and these products targeted a total
of 28 unique cancer indications
63 of trials had trial location data and
the rest did not and we found that each drug
was manufactured was tested in a median of 25
different countries in addition to the united
states including a median of 20 high-income
countries six upper middle income countries
a meeting of one low middle income country
and a median of low zero low-income countries
only one drug in our sample was tested in
a low income country and that was certuro
a tb related treatment was tested in kenya
but 17 drugs were tested in south africa
so within one year of fda approval only three
percent of the drugs in our sample were approved
for marketing in all the countries where they
were tested if you look at five years later
you still only find about 15 of these drugs
approved for marketing where they were tested
on the country level there were 70 countries that
contributed research participants for these fda
approvals and what we found is that seven percent
of these countries got market access to those
drugs within one year of fda approval and even if
you look at five years you're still only finding
about 31 of countries with marketing approval
and these numbers don't change substantially
if you bump it out to seven years thirty percent
of countries stratifying market access by country
income level which is what you see on the screen
now we found that thirteen 13 of high-income
countries got market access to products within one
year compared to zero upper middle and zero lower
middle looking at five years out you see that
46 percent of high-income countries got access
nine percent of upper middle and 22 percent
of lower middle income countries at five years
breaking these findings out by geographical region
market access was lowest in african countries
followed by the middle east middle eastern
countries and access was highest unsurprisingly
in canada and eastern europe at five years
followed by western european countries and oceana
latin american countries and asian countries
fell towards the middle of the pack
as i mentioned at the beginning marketing access
doesn't guarantee that there are enough doses or
that a product is affordable so our team conducted
another study led by reshma ramachandra at yale
a fellow at yale examining market access to
covid19 vaccines in the countries where they
were tested so we focused on the world health
organization vaccines recommended for use
and we found that they were for completed trials
they were tested in also a total of 25 countries
as of september 7th 2021 and we found that among
the 11 high income countries hosting completing
trials completed trials 91 authorized attested
vaccine and received enough doses to vaccinate
a median of 51 52 of their populations age 15
and older however you looked at lower and middle
lower middle and upper middle income countries
the rates of authorization were high 100 and 91
respectively however the median vaccination
rates were much lower they were 31 and 15
of their populations respectively and if you
look at including ongoing and completing trials
the corresponding rates go
up for high income countries
and they go down for all other income
level countries all other income groups
and this is a study that we didn't conduct
this um was done by uh noria hamadees
and that research group looked at drugs
approved by the fda in 2011 and 2012
to see if they were registered and
commercialized but they also looked at
affordability uh in latin american countries uh
where they were tested and what they found is that
30 they looked at 33 products and they expected
to see them registered in 114 different places
and they found that only 60 were registered where
they were tested and that with only one exception
all of the products cost more than
the monthly minimum wage in all those
countries and 12 products cost at least five
times the monthly minimum wage in the country
concluding that most many pharmaceutical products
tested in latin america are unavailable and
or unaffordable to most of the populations
so from an ethics perspective ethicists tend
to agree that communities providing trial
participants should stand to benefit from their
participation and you can find this principle
in the declaration of helsinki and the cio ms
guidelines for international clinical research
a corollary of this principle is that to avoid
exploitation research should not ordinarily be
conducted in a national population that does not
stand to benefit from the knowledge to be gained
or the interventions to be developed and that
language is taken from the helsinki declaration
since this clearly is not consistently happening
we are now building measures for the good from a
scorecard to start tracking our progress and
incenting change in this area where needed
so wrapping up the good form of scorecard is to is
designed to address the key bioethics challenges
around biomedical innovation focusing on clinical
trials sponsored by industry and so far we've
launched the scorecard to address clinical
trial transparency and data sharing practices
and this year we'll be debuting our new equity
measures and rankings for biomedical research
there's evidence suggesting that the good firm
scorecard is having an impact with scores going
up on the measures that we add to the scorecard
and 50 of large scoring companies improving
procedures within 30 days of getting a low
score for the 2019 rankings socially responsible
indices and environmental social governance esg
funds and investors are beginning to use and look
at the rankings and the software that large
companies use to check their own transparency
is building some of our measures into their
software to automate a company's use of the
scorecard or evaluation of how they might score
so we hope to continue to have a beneficial impact
for patients um and continue to develop measures
and pilot them so now i look forward to hearing
everybody's questions and comments jennifer thank
you so much what an intriguing idea coming up with
the good pharma score it kind of reminds me
of a of a zagat score or a michelin stars or
you know and of course uh many of us who are at
universities or a lot of our universities seem to
pay a possibly undue amount of attention to their
us news rankings um it's interesting because each
one of those different ranking systems takes
on kind of a different approach i think that
the zagat score or at least it used to depend
upon you know the rate the rankings available from
um like diners going to restaurants for example so
it'd be basically be you know crowdsourced whereas
the michelin scores for example are you know
expert uh restaurant diners would go and evaluate
them so it's kind of a couple different models
and then i think even u.s news um has a kind of
different number and variety of things that they
rank relative to another university ranking system
like the times of london university once are you
aware of any other systems that attempt to do this
and do they have a different approach than yours
or are you the only game in town at the moment
right well if there were other uh groups
doing this i probably wouldn't have started
so um so the short answer is uh from a bioethics
perspective no however there is one other ranking
uh system related and complementary to our
work but not duplicative and it's the access
to medicines index um which was i think at one
point actually funded by the gates foundation
and atmi looks at the accessibility of
products in low and middle income countries
um but it doesn't overlap at all with our work
that's nice you have your own niche then right for
better or worse uh yes if you're interested in the
social responsibility performance and bioethics
of the pharmaceutical sector you're stuck with
the good from scorecard i think that that's just
fine you know what does the fda have in terms of
its expectations for companies it seems like a lot
of the work that you've drawn from obviously is
that the data that you're mining here comes from
fda approved clinical trials does the fda have
any standards or anything against which people
are supposed to adhere to or is that sort of
loosey goosey i guess so there is it's a good
question so embedded in your question is a larger
a larger question which is um you know what
kind of ethical responsibilities do we want
to ask of companies from a minimal minimal um
ass we'd want them to to to comply with u.s laws
and so although i would you know argue that
ethics is clearly not synonymous with legal
compliance but um there is a law if you're
thinking about transparency and data sharing
in the u.s that requires companies
to report summary results of trials
they conduct non-phase one trials conducted in
patients in the us or by u.s sponsor and what i
tried to show in my initial slides was how narrow
that lawless was right so if it's a large company
a large company sponsors 25 different experiments
for fda approval of their product if you look at
all companies it's about 13 trials per product
and the law covers a median of three of those
and some products are approved based
on zero trials that are subject to
mandatory disclose disclosures under the law
but notwithstanding the narrowness or arguable
narrowness of the law uh a substantial amount of
companies fail to meet baseline legal requirements
so to answer your the long that's a long answer
to say there are um laws right that the things
that the fda could require um however
they're they're not being followed and
the fda the government could impose uh penalties
for non-compliance which it has yet to do
is that is that is that politically motivated
do you feel or financially motivated that the
fda hasn't imposed penalties on some of these
companies well i would so i'm empirical based i
would suggest a qualitative study of fda employees
to find out what happened um but one hunch
is that when the law was originally uh introduced
uh in 2007 in my opinion the language was uh
opaque and it wasn't so i think there was some
exploitation of the ambiguities in the law
and perhaps that caused some challenges in
applying it and um so you know let's hope that
the fda there are a lot of reasons i'm not going
to comment on those uh but let's hope that the fda
starts uh better monitoring and enforcing
uh this law it's just started issuing uh
non-compliance letters to companies for the
first time but it's really only gone out to a
handful of companies um in comparison
to how many should receive such letters
and like i said i don't believe to this
date any civil penalties have been collected
any um monetary penalties okay do you work with
any um legal scholars um who can kind of help
provide guidance and insight on you know kind of
what is allowable or what uh kind of the range
of things that exist within those laws does
that make sense yeah sure well fidel has been
was clarified in 2017 so there's not as much
of a range of allowable sort of interpretations
um but yeah on those papers you'll see a
couple legal scholars michelle mello is
in this law school at stanford um but actually
kind of goes the reverse way we're often
since we're working with legal scholars as we know
more because when you start to apply and measure
uh compliance it raises more questions
than if you just look at the language
so we work together on interpreting the law do
you um you also mentioned that uh the good pharma
score can be applied to medical devices as well
and i think the examples you gave were largely
pharmaceutical companies um do you are you working
with any um or rather working with any data from
medical device companies as they're kind of you
know prototyping or attempting to get data on the
efficacy of a particular medical device at all
yes thank you so much for asking so this year
we are adding medical devices for the first
time so we looked at all of the original
or novel medical devices that the fda approved
in 2017 and benchmark them using the same methods
so you'll have to stay tuned for a couple more
months before those findings come out but it adds
a substantial number of companies and products
to our reviews and every year going forward
you'll now see drugs biologics and medical devices
every year we expand the scorecard incrementally
and this year was the addition of biologics and
devices that's great and all size companies well
and you again have focus it looks like you've
you know most most of most of your data comes
from fda related um activities are you looking
at companies from other countries for example
great britain or the european union or elsewhere
where pharmaceutical scores would also be helpful
the company doesn't have to be based in the u.s
to get ranked they just have to submit a product
for fda approval and we it turns out that
the location of a country actually doesn't
correlate with a change in transparency practice
or score um it's really the size of company
that was that uh trying to find that slide so
products submitted to f to the fda for approval
are not um entirely based in the u.s they're
global and research is globalized so by nature the
studies are all global yeah i guess i i meant the
um uh like the european for example or the british
equivalent of the food and drug administration
can you mine any um information that they have
that's publicly available because there may be
companies that apply for a approval in
one country that don't send something into
the food and drug administration ema approval
perhaps the european medicines association yeah so
there's usually a a strong relation between
say the canadian uh the european and the u.s
drug agency but but so you wouldn't necessarily
have to use the ema data or canadian or in sort of
a developed country but what would be interesting
and what we're not doing is looking at um
not initial novel drugs but um
generics right so because they are often you know
more um they may not all make it to the u.s market
so because we're only looking at novel
products um it makes sense for us to focus on
uh fda ema and um you know canadians uh approved
drugs i see that makes sense now it's interesting
because you were talking about uh i was
writing down a question myself about this
um at this at the very minute you brought
up your slide and kind of answered it for me
was um what is the score that p that a company
gets um related to the size of that company so
i saw like you know amgen was i think number
two on the list and there's a few other major
pharmaceutical companies and as you move down the
list they tended to get smaller so there appeared
to be a relationship there that you answered and
i was also kind of curious about like whether the
score is related to their stock price or you know
some other profit margin related index and i was
just curious if because i presume the size of
the company and their stock prices correlated
so i wouldn't be surprised if the score was also
correlated with their you know some financial
element of that particular company do you find
that you track that kind of information too
um what can you expand on that your sense is
if there's a dip in the price that you'd see
a different score for example i presume that if
if stock price is you know varies linearly with
their score i was just kind of curious
if that's something you see evidence of
yeah we're looking at that right now um stay
tuned you okay i mean i i i have say this the
scorecard i my senses and i have a hunch but we
need to really measure measure the alpha is um
it's a it's a good predictor of potential
future problems like we saw valiant tank in the
scorecard um before the scandals broke out about
it um buying uh supposedly undervalued drugs and
marking them up a medium of 200 percent right
the scandalous business model um valiant is
no more i think it's bausch and lohmer fashion
health and google the right name uh so my hunch
is there is a correlation between transparency
performance possibly also ethics in general and um
you know other factors but we
need to do a deep dive in that
sure um so when you are in in your own
kind of work here what effort do you make
to make the data that you're gathering and
the analyses and their interpretation
open and transparent and accessible
for anyone who wants to dig through this data uh
which i encourage you to do and if you know make
use of it it's on triad it's a non-profit
repository and we put all of our raw data
sheets on dryad every year and they actually
are used a lot um heavily downloaded i think
mostly by lawyers double checking our work i know
one time an industry trade association sort of
hired a communications firm to redo all of
our analyses didn't find much differences
but something i should mention is that we send
all of our data to the companies for validation
so they get all of their raw data sheets and
they have an opportunity to correct anything
that they think might need correcting and if we
can verify what they say through public sources
like other fda documents or other regulatory
body documents we will make corrections and
sometimes i would say not infrequently there
are typos in the fda documents um so that
validation process can be helpful that's great
um what role could there be for people doing
data science and ai related work uh as two
different elements of this um on something like
this to help kind of expand the dimensionality
and the the nuance that goes into the good pharma
score i would love to hear from you know you guys
what ethical challenges you're encountering or
things you'd like to see done better for sure if
you're doing data science and using ai to analyze
data there's not a lot of transparency in that
space right the algorithms used are often opaque
um sometimes because they're proprietary yeah and
so i think it's really important that we start to
talk about what transparency means in those data
sets and for those algorithms also that we think
about the same things they just presented right
the are there biases in the data um you know who
are who's represented in the data we know genomic
data for example tends to be overwhelmingly um
caucasian and uh you know from certain countries
global south being underrepresented and then when
uh you know it's the exact same challenges we're
seeing here when um non-high-income countries
or the global south are included in data sources
you know what are they getting in return for that
um just like we said here we tend
to test drug if we test drugs in
low-income countries we're not even making
them available on the market let alone
affordable or insufficient supply so we definitely
don't want to repeat these mistakes in the newer
emerging space of ai and big data so i think
now is really a good time to start thinking
through that and trying to set a chart a course
forward in a good a good way and a good path
are have you communicated with um lawmakers
senators congressmen um and others who
may be influential in helping to craft
new laws or tidy up pro existing laws that
may kind of encourage pharmaceutical companies
to not be as transparent there is a group at
yale called crit the collaboration for
research integrity and transparency
that is full of a powerhouse of lawyers and
they have used these findings and the findings
of others to submit um you know to work on the
advocacy on the policy level uh with some success
um so this work supports their work but i am not
an advocate right i am a sort of a researcher um
so certainly partner with groups like crit um
but if you're you know if you're looking for
uh lobbyists and advocates i look more towards
them not lobbyists but advocates for um policy
change does the um do the does the score and the
sub scales that you're measuring one do you see
that growing over say the next five years in terms
of the number of i mean it seems like you are the
number of different dimensions are there any other
dimensions that um you know are maybe ones that
you're considering but haven't quite fully fleshed
out yet where um they may be um areas of further
growth over the next say five years or so yeah so
the idea of the scorecard is to be comprehensive
and look at all of the bioethics and social
responsibility concerns we have about companies
particularly those that are important to get
right for patient health for people for our health
all around the world um so after clinical trial
transparency and data sharing and adding the
medical devices we're going to target equity in
biomedical research looking at those two issues to
begin with who's included in research right fair
inclusion and representation of groups beginning
with sex gender age race and ethnicity and then
not only looking at who's included but then what
are they getting in exchange for participating
and on that we'll look on the national level
which countries are participating
in clinical research and helping
us develop drugs and vaccines and seeing what
they're getting in exchange for participation
starting very humbly with looking at whether they
get market access and then ideally expanding also
into looking at the affordability and availability
of products so including drug pricing akin to
uh that study that i presented in about south
american countries or latin american countries
um that will keep us busy for i would suspect
you know a good amount of money um we can go
faster the more funding we have which we're
working on uh and then after that we'll have to
you know step back and see uh what's going on but
again the the end goal is to have a comprehensive
bioethics and social responsibility index
i am exploring partnering with a couple
groups to add in the environmental impact
of pharma to create a more comprehensive esg
index and it's remarkable that we just don't
have an esg index focused on pharma so within
five years the dream or the ideal goal is
to have a comprehensive esg set of measures
and rankings that are used by investors and
anyone with you know any kind of lever to
really catalyze or continue the change
that we need to see in the sector
given its important role in all of our health and
i think that the kobit 19 pandemic has highlighted
how important it is to get things right with
this sector in terms of the way it develops
drugs and vaccines and the way they ultimately
become accessible and reachable for all of us
well jennifer that on that note it's a great place
to kind of stop you've given us so much to think
about and kind of think about the the social
responsibility the ethical responsibility of
major pharmaceutical companies and how we
might rank them and kind of sort them uh
hopefully encourage those that are not doing
such a good job about ways at which they might
approve and how we might um help to develop best
practice standards based upon these different
target areas that you you're focusing on i look
forward to seeing how this develops over the next
five to ten years or so thank you so much
for sharing your work with us and thank
you everybody for for joining us today um we
really appreciate it and we wish you all a good
friday and a very good weekend and we'll we'll
see you next week thanks again jennifer thanks